from The New York Times Epstein
documents naming prominent figures
expected to be released soon the
documents related to a lawsuit involving
gilain Maxwell an associate of the
disgraced financier Jeffrey Epstein are
anticipated to include names previously
redacted uh some people actually say
that she may have been the Mastermind um
but we don't know we don't know Epstein
appears to be by all accounts The
Mastermind but she was more than just an
associate she was basically his second
in command they going to mention court
documents are set to be released this we
know we've been waiting a for it but
there's speculation as to who's going to
be on that list now multiple news
reports have said former President Bill
Clinton will be among those names to
fact conservative commentators have
jumped on now hold on there a minute
what does that mean conservative
commentators jumped on this because it
was ABC and a bunch of other prominent
mainstream Outlets that reported it so
wouldn't you first say that several
corporate news outlets jumped on news
that Bill Clinton may be among those
named and then critics of Bill Clinton
went wow look at that I love it New York
Times uh never stop being you they say
uh uh although there's no indication
that will be in connection with
allegations of wrongdoing and Miss jefra
has not accused Clinton of any
misconduct his office said in 2019 that
he had flown in Epstein's private plane
but had no knowledge of Epstein's crimes
and a spokesman pointed to that
statement on Tuesday uh I'm going to go
ahead and say I don't believe you youo
the statements we've gotten from victims
that are confirmed to be victims are
horrifying and I don't believe even they
say that we may learn the names of their
housekeepers I'm like yeah lock them up
housekeepers get locked up too were if
you were a maid for Epstein while he was
bringing in young girls so that powerful
Elites could fly to a private island to
rape them and you were cleaning up the
mess you are an accomplice who aided and
abetted human traffickers and child
exploitation yeah you get locked up too
so if you're going to tell me that Bill
Clinton is flying on this plane had no
idea what's going on a come on of all
the people they could try to claim
there's no evidence of wrongdoing you
know if if they said Bill Gates like
Bill Gates FLW in his play but had no
evidence of any wrongdoing we'd all roll
our eyes and be like okay maybe but I
doubt it with Bill Clinton's like come
on that guy we all know what that guy's
all about you think he doesn't know
what's going on I wouldn't be surprised
if it turns out that he was facilitating
it we'll see who who who else what do
you guys think I think it's weird you
know first of all when they say the
rightwing part cuz rightwing for the
corporate press has become a synonym for
conspiratorial oh it's conservative so
conservative has become a synonym for
conspiratorial you know cuz they're
trying to give you that slant because
they don't want people to believe who
might be on the list or not but like
you're saying with the with the maids
and stuff I just think about those
reports that came out years ago about
those dental chairs or like torture type
chairs that were in these apartments of
his in like weird places and weird rooms
and who's cleaning up this place who's
not who who's not reporting all this
weird activity of these children uh so
I'm I'm looking forward to it coming out
but I'm also not going to be surprised
when people look at it and spin it to to
support whatever narrative they want to
sell so they see Trump they're going to
go with the Trump angle you see Clinton
they're going to go with the Clinton
angle and it's going to become like this
Trum everyone's going to be on it right
every name will be attached but I I I
bet Trump's in it and the media is going
to go nuts and be like Trump listed in
Epstein documents anybody that can
anyone that's you know from the right
that is on the list is going to be the
focus from the mainstream media if they
talk about it I do think the mainstream
media wants this to you know quiet down
and go away um overall I think it's bad
for the establishment because everyone
knows that Jeffrey Epstein was was
involved with a lot of people look the
guy was a a master networker there's
there's rumors about his connections to
uh intelligence agencies the likelihood
of him using Epstein Island using the
island to get dirt on people that are in
positions of power offering them things
that are illegal and then getting you
know having video or having information
about it or whatever and using that to
not just Finance his own uh his own
lifestyle but also to use that to
influence essentially you know movers
and shakers in World politics and and
and big business um there's not an
argument there's not an argument about
whether or not that is what is going on
it's generally a consensus gilan I
forgot I'm probably mispronouncing gain
why do we care to pronounce her name
right when when I call her gizan people
wor about her pronouns you're right I
just call her gan from now on I tried
just because I try to pronounce
everything right but whatever yeah Goman
is in in jail for that's it now she's a
government issue um for you know
facilitating the the trafficking of
human beings no one to no one to no one
so these things are these things have
happened there's and no matter how many
no matter how the the media decides it
wants to uh cast this or
or what narrative they want to go with
yeah these things are actually true
actually have happened and I think that
the public might be numb to it I just
got to I got to say this because you
know it's like it's it's been the
holiday we've been off for a couple
weeks and I haven't had the opportunity
to say Civil War on a for a little while
you it's like just got to get that out
you know you know that Meme where the
guy's like sweat in his veins Popp
that's what it's like it's like so uh
but no I just want to point out cuz I
love doing that time travel test where
I'm like imagine you went back in time x
amount of years and then explained how X
is happening Y is happening now I just
want to also point out that imagine if
you went back to
2012 and got up on stage in front of a
whole bunch of people Super Bowl Super
Bowl and you went on stage and said
powerful Global Elites are involved in
child trafficking with multi with
multi-billionaires with former
presidents and politicians flying on
private islands they'd be like get this
crackpot out of here conspiracy theory
there are still a lot of people that
will say that exact thing and believe
that's fine if because they're the
crackpots now I'm saying back then when
Alex Jones is banging on the table be
like they got planes and they're flying
these kids to this island they were like
this guy's lost his mind he's insane now
you I don't know if it's Civil War
related or whatever just think about how
far we've come to where you get in you
get an Uber and you'll be like oh did
you hear that uh uh Global powerful
political Elite sex trafficking Rings
about to have names released the Uber
drivers going to be like oh yeah I heard
that
it's just it's just a ubiquitous fact yo
go back to 2012 and tell people that
sometime soon after Epstein will happen
the world will shut down Global Elites
will literally destroy the world the
world off boom and then and then like
like you're saying with Epsy talking
about that and it's kind of nonchalant
now anywhere I go in the world when I'm
getting in the car I like to talk about
how that person experienced covid and
lockdowns we all have a shared traumatic
fear ritual experience that is wild
crazy when you put it like that it is
wild when was when was the Epstein stuff
exposed in 2019 exposed or when did he
uh well no no the exposure stuff
happened a long like Alex Jones was
talking about this 15 years ago but uh
when was it actually that he got he was
getting arrested what year was that I
don't 19 right was it 19 so 19 and then
he uh he and that's and that's when
that's when the camera's shut off the
guards fell asleep that was 2020 yeah
you know it's just come
oned and they're just like yo hold on
turn everything off we cannot let this
happen time of him being in jail I was
trying I was reporting on a story about
a guy went to the jail for a crazy uh
drug problem he was a former cop he went
to prison I'm I'm writing about it and
uh he turns out to be the guy who was in
the prison cell with Epstein who beat
him up I never re I never found a place
at that time when I was freelancing to
publish a story but I kept going around
being like this is insane not only is
that whole story insane with a guy
former cop like taking four uh
immigrants lives and burying them on a
pig farm in New York then he got a cell
phone in his jail cell no one knows how
he got it then he beat up epsi then
epsin was put in that room in that cell
where he hung himself no no no no didn't
wasn't it reportedly the it was reported
that his roommate beat him up but then
it was changed reporting that the
roommate said no he hurt himself he
tried to kill himself he said I didn't
do anything yeah I'm pretty sure go look
up that guy forget his name right now
he's come on I just love it it's like
they put Epstein in a cell with this guy
who's super ripped and then and then EP
makes an attempt didn't Epstein like say
something like no I didn't I it's been a
while I know I forget all those the guy
was a former cop who was a murderer I
just I just love how Wild it is that
like literally no one I shouldn't say
Okay figuratively No One Believes that
Epstein took his own life but there are
these there are these corporate press
journals like he certainly did it makes
a lot of sense it's like Wikipedia said
there's a video diagram like someone
made a video like CGI of how he would
how how they claim he would have done it
and I saw this clip and I'm like it is
the stupidest thing I've ever SE seen
because the room's so small Epstein is I
what's what's the yoga pose called where
you like you you you sit with your legs
under you and then lay all the way back
down you know what I'm talking about so
like I don't know why I'm deferring to
Surge so you're like you sit on your
feet yeah you like you bend to the knees
and you're sitting on your and then you
lay all the way back your thighs are on
your on your calves yeah yeah yeah so
right and so like your legs are folded
and you're laying back and supposedly
what Epstein did was he laid on the bed
that way because the ceiling wasn't high
enough and then lurched forward with his
legs bent to jump off the the bed cuz
there was no actual way to hang himself
and they supposedly only had certain
type of easily tear away sheets like
that they said he hung wasn't he wearing
a smock or something oh come on dude the
cameras break the guards fall asleep
we're just like dude I'm sorry it you
know would be really funny if Epstein's
like in prison he's like how can I make
this the least believable thing ever and
like his plan and then the guards are
like damn it he got us he waited till
they were sleeping he broke the cameras
look I mean realistically like even if
like whether you believe he killed
himself or not kind of doesn't matter
because the reason that he killed
himself is because what was going to
happen so like or the reason he's dead
whether he killed himself or whether he
was killed by the glint it's not like
the clintons well I mean come on
everybody knows it everyone thinks it's
Hillary um but it doesn't but it's not
like people in positions of power in
governments are are strangers to
ordering the the the killing of human
beings right if you're the president and
you order a strike they you know you'll
carry it out that is mafioso crap it's
just that it's polished up and made
acceptable if if if you go to someone
and say did you know that Barack Obama
secretly ordered the killing of
Americans yeah like they like shut up
maybe you pull on the New York Times
here you go read about it it's not a
conspiracy this is in the New York Times
I mean maybe the New York Times is lying
I don't trust them I think the same
thing that you were saying earlier when
when Phil was talking earlier I was
thinking it's amazing that now we're
2024 finally but the people hear things
like Epstein and they know yeah there's
the people running things Bill Clinton
and Bill Gates these people that there
are probably tapes of them doing
horrible horrible things they're
compromised they're blackmailed the
people in power are these sick sick
people and that that's mainstream now
that the Alex Jones was right jar is
very full and everybody recognizes it so
we're an amazing time to be alive the
fact that this is popular Consciousness
now and we can move things in a very
different direction than has gone on for
decades I'm really excited for uh
throwing money into the Alex Jones was
right jar as it pertains to
fifth-dimensional
creatures and and the chimeras and the
cell phone towers and all that stuff
when that's proven true I'm gon to be
like man I'm just GNA empty my wall and
just just Shuffle it all in there you
know Alex Goes On The Joe Rogan show and
he's like they got multi-dimensional
beings that are you know we know the
Chim are out there we know we know
they're they've definitely
odd creatures labs and and put weird
things on aborted fetuses in that that
was it Philly or they definitely do
weird stuff and I think the issue with
Alex is that he does get a lot right but
I think he'll see a story about like
chimeras and then he takes like this one
small story and then Dives so far into
it and and stretches it you know to
something bigger than it really is I
also know when when you talk about
sometimes it's like there's just so much
information that's coming out at once
you got to like narrow it down and then
follow that path you know uh cuz there
there's a lot and a lot those kind eras
you can look up those the things that
they were making out of the fetuses uh
disturbing thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net